fin septembre nous avons frémit devant
les aventures de james bond avec octo
poussive odette rogers moore voici venir
mercredi prochain une autre aventure du
même james bond jamais plus jamais ce
film bat déjà les records d'affluence à
new york
mais la vedette n'est plus rogers moore
devinez qui est votre 007 de noël france
roche a eu la chance de le suivre
pendant son bref séjour en france
imaginez que vous êtes producteur d'une
aventure de 007 que vous arrivez le
second dans la saison puisque le bond
d'octobre avec roger moore est encore à
la fiche que faites vous là meilleur
film peut-être mais surtout une
meilleure promotion vous embarquer par
exemple en avion des journalistes de
toute l'europe vers une ville attirante
disons monte carlo où leur distribuer
une abondante littérature vendant votre
bande à vous qui n'est autre que deviner
voyons le premier en date il ya 21 ans
mais oui sean connery vous atterrissez
sur la côte d'azur avec le producteur le
réalisateur de james bond girl et le
couple connery
on aurait dû prévoir le soleil mais
james 007 ces gadgets feront tout
oublier et les photographes
c'est essentiel sont là vous prévoyez
une conférence de presse bilingue votre
chope connerie est aussi très au point
il a toujours le mot pour rire votre
avis
quoi quand je joue parce qu'il est plus
âgée que moi
il a aussi le geste qu'on attendait
le soir présentation à la famille
princière de monaco et souper de gala ce
sont les propres petites filles de la
femme de shawn qui tiennent les bouquets
caroline stéphanie albert et leur papa
qui inaugure une belle petite barbe en
collier salut félicite et aime le film
puis les photographes se jettent sur les
ex bond girls invitées par exemple
ursula andress ou claudine auger tandis
que shawn donne des autographes sur
papier et même vous allez voir sur
chemise
celle là même avec laquelle il s'est
lancé dans une scène plus dangereuse que
toutes les autres un tango j'ai vérifié
elle a servi tout ça dépasse en pure
perte jamais plus jamais abattu à new
york tous les records de 0,05 dans le
premier mois 42 millions $ et à chaque
conférence de presse la même question
quelle différence entre votre bonté
celui de ranger world notre approche est
plus réaliste et nous l'espérons avec
plus d'humour physique roger joue dans
un autre sens celui du comique il a fait
quand même pas mal d'acrobaties la
preuve
sportif il veut bien courir sur des
trains en marche mais il déteste un seul
élément lourd je ne suis pas fou à
l'idée de plonger dans l'eau j'ai
tendance à l'austro phobies et lumière
être immergés par 15 mètres de fond dans
une cloche de 3 mai cube avec des
requins tout autour mais barbara guerra
mérite tous les éloges
elle avait aussi peur que moi et
pourtant elle a fait ils voyaient ainsi
depuis trois mois après monte-carlo il
aura encore cinq capitales affaires et
six semaines à tirer et puis shaun
pourra dire ouf et toucher ces dollars
key